[Music]
when you search through history books
you will find many anecdotes on the role
that alcohol and other addictive
substances played in shaping societies
throughout human history the Pharaohs of
ancient Egypt paid their farm laborers
in bread and beer Greek wine was one of
the most prized commodities of the
ancient world so when the Carthaginians
sold their low-quality wine abroad they
falsely labeled dn-4 as as Greek wine
the British notoriously forced access
and control over the 19th century
Chinese economy by illegally selling
opium to its people
but no historic relationship between a
society and an addictive substance is as
fascinating sinister and barely talked
about as the relationship between Russia
and vodka there is nothing special about
vodka it has no taste no flavor no smell
is just F fool alcohol simply produced
from wheat or rye and these simple not
too special facts of vodka is exactly
what made it so special its simplicity
allowed it to be produced and consumed
on mass by simple peasants throughout
Eastern Europe beginning in the 8th
century any peasant could make it and
any peasant could sell it until the
1480s
until then the lands we know as Russia
we're set of small independent
principalities and kingdoms until Ivan
the third became the ruler of the Duchy
of Moscow and by conquest United the
principalities on the one Russian
Kingdom of which he became the Tsar Ivan
established a centralised government
with a centralized autocratic rule
controlled by the king and as he built
his state he noticed the popularity of
that cheap intoxicating spirit amongst
his peasants and had an idea he banned
the production and sale of alcohol by
peasants and declared the production and
sale of alcohol a royal privilege all
alcohol was now the property of the
Russian crown and could only be produced
by and bought from the Russian crown
this was a guaranteed source of revenue
for the Russian royal family a monopoly
on a cheap product that everyone wanted
a which could be very cheaply produced
on mass throughout the centuries the
Tsar's opened vodka plant after vodka
plant pumping out cheap alcohol while
filling their own pockets a system that
was so profitable that when Catherine
the Great rewarded lesser Nobles for
their service she didn't give them land
but vodka production and selling grants
to cash in on this lucrative monopoly a
system that lasted for almost four
hundred and twenty eight years and as
much as this may sound like just a mere
little interesting historic anecdote on
a long gone mercantile economic system
there is far more to it than that
something sinister the reverberations of
which still echo throughout Russian
society to this day alcohol is a poison
harmful to the soul and body therefore
it is a great sin to drink alcohol and
to offer it to others and it is even a
greater sin to produce and sell this
poison this phrase is from Tolstoy when
czar nicholas ii had to rescind powers
to an elected body in 1905 one of the
first things the russian liberals and
social democrats who were newly elected
into a position of power wished to do
was to combat the massive alcoholism
problems of russia the first step was to
ask the famous and revered novelist to
write a warning label to be printed on
every single bottle of vodka the tsar
who owned the entire alcohol industry
refused because the system the czars
established over the course of four
hundred years was not only a source of
revenue by controlling the entire market
they also determined the price and
consequently kept the population drunk
on a constant mass supply of cheap and
widely available vodka a peasant who
wastes his money on vodka is too drunk
to think of his situation and how he got
into it too drunk to organize any
protest against his circumstances so
drunk he beats his kids into being
drunks like him and so drunk he beats
his wife into submission in the end that
peasant is a peasant in service of
ensuring the security of the regime that
keeps him drunk
the czars of Russia established a
profitable system of state subsidized
alcoholism which not only ensured them
personal wealth but the security of
their regime there were in essence drug
dealers or at least reliant on the same
addiction fed market that a drug dealer
would rely on alcohol addiction is a
horrible disease it increases blood
pressure inflamed and swollen blood
vessels kidney pancreas and liver
failure that leads to an excess of fat
cells creating deformed abdomens but far
from trusty individual effects alcohol
is also part of a vicious social circle
of
misery nobody wakes up one day and
decides to become an addict
addiction is pre conditioned on misery
and despair
it appears where there is despair and
hopelessness and perversely increases
that hopelessness the alcoholic not only
becomes more hopeless and miserable
themselves but will contribute to the
misery and hopelessness of those around
him perplexingly addiction on the
massive social scale creates social
Steiff and misery while simultaneously
robbing those affected by it of the
means to do something about it this is
why the drug trade comes with violent
social decline of disaffection of
communities because it uses misery as an
economic commodity it is because of this
and largely forgotten today that the
Russian Communist Party was a
prohibitionist party that advocated for
the banning of liquor in early Soviet
propaganda you will find this reflected
as well as in old Soviet movies in which
the revolutionaries smash liquor bottles
as if they were chains that had
constrained them Leninism was strictly
prohibitionist and declared alcohol to
be a vice by which the bourgeoisie
subjugated and controlled the
proletariat consequently after the
Bolshevik take over the Czar's vodka
plants were all shut down and closed for
a while when Stalin seized power he
reopened the vodka plants started
filling bottles again and distributed
them cheaply amongst the public
Stalin pretty much rebuilt the old
Czarist system of subsidized alcoholism
that the revolutionaries had tried to
dismantle he just renamed it to the
people's vodka in a very cynical move
the Russian people already had a
people's vodka for 400 years this series
of events is commented on by George
Orwell in his famous book Animal Farm
and often overlooked scene where the
animals in their revolution destroy all
the alcohol they found in the house of
the farmer Jones except for Napoleon who
steals himself away with some liquor and
the Zara's system which was
reestablished by Stalin remained in
place throughout the remaining 60 years
of Soviet history its effects were most
strongly felt starting in the 1970s and
throughout the 1980s during the Soviet
Union's increasing economic decline in
those days there was not much to work
for there was not much to celebrate
there was a lost war still being fought
in Afghanistan and there was not much
for the stage to sell but there was
always money to be
aid when socialism fails by selling
bottles of cheap vodka to a miserable
public the recent HBO series Chernobyl
did an excellent job at hinting to its
audience how by the late 1980s Russian
society had a deep-seated and systematic
alcoholism problem the store Shanaya
vodka bottles you see in the series are
also somewhat famous because you
couldn't close them anymore once you
took the cap off they were made that way
because in production the assumption was
that the average Russian wants opening a
vodka bottle would finish it in one
sitting there for closing the bottle
wasn't necessary by the late 1980s the
alcoholism problem reached such an
extent that Gorbachev in desperation
enacted a prohibition of liquor this
resulted in the mass appears of illegal
vodka plants throughout the country I
was therefore abandoned today almost 30
years after the collapse of the Soviet
Union the problems remain the system of
state-subsidized alcoholism no longer
exists the vodka plants though were
privatized and are owned by oligarchs
who still sell the vodka at cheap prices
no measures were taken by the Russian
government to stem the banal systemic
alcoholism and excessive alcohol
consumption of the Russian public the
ramifications of such of course felt in
crime rates productivity and social
decline and misery Russia will
eventually not get around having to
confront a legacy of 400 years of
alcoholism and this is more than just a
history lesson let alone restricted to
Russia think of the current opiate
crisis in the United States how the
current response to social misery is to
dish out pills to help people stomach
through the days and lives how fully
legal dependency on addictive substances
was created in the United States at a
profit that uses social and individual
misery as a market commodity and more to
the point Hyde is largely ignored and
not a topic of contention drug riddled
and miserable communities often find
themselves within such a state because
it is the misery and hopelessness that
creates the perfect market conditions
for addictive substances which
consequently increase the misery and
violence while robbing communities of
the ability to rid themselves they're
off the entirety of our understanding of
addiction and how it plays into society
through the ills it creates is largely
flawed and dominated far too much by a
judgemental standard that reduces the
problem to individuals to be punished
rather than social
in need of solutions if you're
interested in this topic and want to
know more I recommend to you to read
drink a cultural history of alcohol by
Ian Gately
[Music]